basically when I work like four hours a
week last quarter
how it works real company that was a
Twitter Tech lead admitting that he and
the most of his colleagues only work
four hours every week despite this
terrible performance this guy was likely
paid around 341 thousand dollars every
single year but another way he was
basically getting paid over sixteen
hundred dollars per hour clearly Elon
put an end to this at Twitter but this
is still very much a reality within most
tech companies now I don't want to throw
all Engineers under the bus as a
substantial portion of them or the exact
opposite working 60 to 80 hours every
week but with that being said there is a
significant number of Engineers just
like this in fact this community is so
large that there is a name for these
people rest investors they just rest the
invest their insanely High compensation
packages you would think that managers
hate these type of people and that
they're constantly looking to expose and
fire these freeloaders but that's not
actually the case in fact a lot of
managers do this themselves and they
sometimes even encourage their team to
do it as well this one high-level
engineer at Facebook for example was
making a million dollars per year and
leading about 36 people while the pay
and Prestige was great she was getting
burnt out with her job so she did the
respectable thing and told her boss who
was likely a senior director that she
was going to leave in about six months
she was willing to finish up all the
projects that she had already taken on
but didn't want any more to this her
boss told her to not come to work the
next day in any other industry or even a
legacy tech company this means you're
fired don't bother showing up tomorrow
at Facebook though this meant this don't
come to work you're burned out and need
a break just don't talk about it and
everyone will assume you're on someone
else's team clearly this is not a group
of rebels that are pushing the
boundaries this is a systematic Trend at
these companies many companies are
cracking down on this with the layoffs
more recently but for the most part they
just turn a blind eye to this entire
situation so here's why Fang Engineers
are allowed to work so little while
getting paid so much
foreign
factors that make resting investing
possible is simply the economics of
these companies unlike a factory or a
bottling plant these tech companies have
insanely high gross margins Apple 43
Google 55 Nvidia 56 and Facebook 78 so
really their only major expense is human
labor as their cost of goods sold is
virtually zero in fact at Visa their
gross margin is straight up 100 as for
the tech companies that don't have high
gross margins yet well they usually just
have infinite VC funding so they end up
in the same boat with that being said
the top priority for leaders of these
companies is to Simply reach as many
people as possible as quickly as
possible to maximize growth efficiency
is not something that they have ever
really prioritized until recently and
it's no wonder why focusing on growth is
simply way more beneficial here's the
thing these companies are usually able
to grow 30 to 50 percent per year for
for multiple decades straight Amazon for
example hasn't even had a single quarter
of negative Revenue growth since the
beginning of this chart so it makes no
sense to focus on the 20 or 30 percent
of employees that are leeches or Worse
get the people who are working hard to
waste time reading out these freeloaders
When leaders can just focus on growing
the entire Company by 50 but all of that
is just half the puzzle the other half
is that the employees also enjoy super
friendly economics if an engineer is
living paycheck to paycheck and
struggling to make rent you can bet that
they're gonna work hard to keep their
job but this is rarely the case with
Engineers if anything they're struggling
to keep up with their upskilled Silicon
Valley life with their 2 million dollar
mortgage and Tesla Model as plaid
realistically though these Engineers
have absolutely no problem paying for a
base standard of living especially with
remote work becoming more popular in
other words they're not exactly
dependent on their jobs so they're not
exactly scared of getting fired in fact
they often don't even care for their job
they're not looking for a promotion or
to climb the ladder or do something
impactful the only reason they're still
working at the company is to cash in on
the stock compensation that unlocks in
12 or 24 months and then hopefully score
another large package right after that
if they don't get the package they're
looking for they'll just jump ship to
another company who will pay them what
they want now you might be saying who
would hire such a bum well the number
one factor that gets you a job at these
companies is how well you interview and
how well you can solve coding problems
and guess what these guys are stars at
this that's how they got their original
job itself they know what to do they
just choose not to do it so unless their
previous manager gives them just an
absolutely awful referral if they're
even asked for a referral these people
are able to jump from job to job and the
coast as needed so if you want to fire
them go ahead they'll just turn around
and find better paying jobs anyway
foreign
working out the reality is that there's
often just not much to do with many of
these jobs to begin with when someone
hears that you're working at Google they
instantly assume that you must be
working on something super cool or at
least something familiar maybe you're
working on the YouTube algorithm or
Google ads or even Google bard but only
the elite of the elite get to be on
those teams everyone else is tasked with
the monotonous work of maintaining and
upgrading their existing systems in
other words the average googler isn't
strategizing how Bard can overtake chat
GPT rather they're probably working on
the 423rd iteration of a Google Places
API with five other Engineers that will
likely never see the light of day the
purpose of this iteration is likely
something like to reduce request times
from three quarters of a second to half
a second for Apple M1 devices the team
probably optimized the code within a
matter of hours but now they're waiting
days for approval from upper management
in the meantime they're just writing
some documentation and having useless
meetings as they wait to go home every
day that is unfortunately the scope of
most engineers in big Tech obviously not
that exciting and not that different
from traditional jobs as these companies
grew so did their inefficiencies and
bureaucracy and so many Engineers were
simply stuck between the wheels now an
active employee might ask to be placed
on more teams and take on more work but
for a passive employee who is willing to
do what they're asked but nothing more
there's simply not much more to do it
than 20 hours of work per week this
brings us into our next type of rest
investor which is the 10x engineer 10x
Engineers aren't exactly trying to work
as little as possible in just Coast in
fact they may be actively going for a
promotion they just don't need all that
much time to kill it at their job when
you think about it this is really not
that surprising given that these
companies are looking to hire the best
talent possible no matter their cost
it's only natural that they attract a
substantial number of superstars these
people are simply able to achieve what's
expected or even go above and beyond
within a matter of 20 hours per week and
given that most tech companies value
results over hours worked these people
fit right in Netflix for example offers
unlimited paid time off the reason being
that they don't care about you clocking
in every day they care about what value
you provide and these 10x Engineers more
than carry their weight so despite
working a low number of hours these
Engineers aren't exactly resting they're
simply super productive when they do
work and they likely have several major
commitments outside of their job like
working on a startup or running a
YouTube channel the bottom line is that
unless you're aggressively trying to
climb the corporate ladder there's
simply no need to work anymore whether
you're a passive engineer or a 10x
engineer
foreign
much of what we discussed so far simply
seems to be circumstantial tech
companies just happen to have great
economics and inefficiencies and
bureaucracy and all of that really the
only reason that rest investors exist is
because these companies want them to
exist in fact not only do they want them
to exist they were literally the ones
who created them you see the history of
rust investors date back to the origins
of these companies themselves their
first 50 Engineers the first 100
Engineers these guys were the OG best
investors hold on back up how could
these guys have been resting investing
when the company was at its most
critical State well they weren't at
least not for the first five or ten
years back then they were actually
busting their butts scaling Google or
Facebook or whatever else but eventually
the company makes it to the other side
they become profitable they hire large
teams and all the groundwork has been
laid in the meantime the original
Workforce has also become
extraordinarily rich each of them
probably only got like a 0.1 percent
stake in the company but that itself is
worth tens of millions if not hundreds
of millions so where do these people go
from here well the most logical step
would be to just retire but these guys
aren't usually the retiring type they're
more likely to join another startup at
an executive level position or found
their own startup likely in an adjacent
field and see this is where the problem
arises given that these guys have been
around since the beginning they are well
aware of all the mistakes Google or
Facebook made along the way and how to
avoid these if they did it again this
makes these individuals a massive asset
for startups but also a massive
liability for Google and Facebook for
obvious reasons these companies don't
want their early employees to help out
or even create competitors so they go to
these employees and tell them hey Jeff
we know how hard you worked for this
company over the past 10 years and how
instrumental you've been so we'd like to
give you a 100 million stock package and
the title of a senior vice president of
BS Department the only caveat is that
you have to stick around for another 10
years to unlock the entire package by
which point that'll actually be worth a
billion dollars so you definitely want
to stick around in the meantime of
course do a good job asking your vice
president but you don't have to work at
a bone or anything and this is where it
all begins these companies are
essentially bribing these employees to
not leave as long as they don't become
effective employees for other companies
that's a win initially this strategy was
only reserved for the most elite
employees but it has since worked its
way down the corporate ladder a senior
manager at Google for example could
easily switch to being an extremely
pivotal director or even VP at a startup
so Google basically just hands them a
half a million a year and tells them to
chill out likely the best evidence of
this is Google's hiring strategy itself
until recently they didn't even know
what team their highest would end up in
because they didn't hire based on need
they would just post to of job listings
like software engineer it wasn't until
they test and verified your skills that
they even tried to find a team for you
with every hire they're basically like
oh shoot this guy's actually skilled we
can't let him work anywhere else uh
let's just find a team for him and
that's why Fang Engineers work so little
but earn so much it's because it's all
part of the bigger plan tap GPT has
taken this to the next level with 900
000 salaries check out this video to
learn more but until then I'm Hari and
I'll see you guys on the next one
[Music]